no but seriously to all of you because I
know we all have jobs before these jobs
so like what were some of yours I'll
start with you bold yeah the main job
that I really had I was uh directing
traffic at the Rose Bowl but I got fired
the first week because I went in fell
asleep and there was an accident that
happened and I was supposed to be there
to help direct that well you were fired
for a good reason
okay like maybe not your calling because
I delivered pizza four years
I delivered pizza I was a girl I was
Domino's okay okay whatever mine was
better
everyone's world and you're sitting no I
did I did pizza - it's hard though I
love pizza so I had to be like no like
so good mm what was one of your jobs I
had a few I would get a pawn shop like
six years yeah
[Laughter]
you want some Victoria Secret okay well
what about you I was driving uber and
lyft when I did this movie so I did a
lot of that but before that I don't know
when I was a kid I wanted to like I
always try to convince my parents to
like do the subway thing when I put down
a hat and I would like to sing and I
beatboxed a lot growing up so like I
would convince my parents to let go and
and hustle for money that way but they
would never let me so that was kind of
like what I wanted to do but they didn't
dream crushed yeah are in a very
successful film so what about you what
did you do for oh wait you were acting
like 13 yeah but now that was puppy BS
there's no pain you work 15 hours seven
years old they pay you $50 he's kind of
I think I would have been better off at
Papajohn yeah yeah I did act my mother
made me set that money aside for college
and then I didn't end up going to
college but then she still wouldn't let
me have anyway as long as I had to work
she didn't give you a doll
I'm marrying her she's great woman a
brilliant woman actually but she
I mostly work construction we work
construction in the summers in high
school and after that and that was the
only real job that I am as a croissant
shop movie theater and do other things
but like and so we Matt and I worked at
this construction site and we did demo
we were kind of the low man on the totem
pole and I remember one time going by
this guy and me mad and I was like oh
man this is Bruno I'm tired of Bob's
complaining guy watch my needle that's
why you should have gone to college like
I probably now has like a hit house you
know who you know the mean and then you
know I worked sure our jobs so we got
new hunting and at that point it was
that was we sold this script and I
thought I was set for life $300,000
$300,000 I just put it with that fun you
got 150 then agent manager thing taxes
no $75,000 so I want you just buy a new
Jeep Cherokee which left me with $20,000
which almost covered the insurance for
the year I managed a ceccolini lottery
and simultaneously go broke you could
have used Shannon up subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel please don't make me keep going